james and carly caught a lizard in their
backyard its body is 17 8 inches long
and its tail is 10 8 inches long
what is the length of the lizard's body
entailed together so good thing we have
the the lizard obediently standing next
to our our measuring stick or our ruler
or whatever this happens to be and we
have it marked off in inches and not
only that we have it marked off in
eighths of inches notice this is an inch
and we have one two three four five six
seven eight sections of that actual inch
so let's see 17 8 inches long this is
going to be 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16
17.
this right over here is 17 8
17 8 which you might notice is also
equal to 2 and one-eighth
eight goes into 17 two times with a
remainder of one but we won't talk about
that just yet but we see that's the
length of
that's the length of the lizard's body
seventeen eighths i just counted off 17
of these eights right over here 17 8 and
then they say that the tail is 10 8
inches long
the tail is 10 8 inches long so it's
another 1
7 8
9 10. so this distance right over here i
just counted off 10 8.
so that's another 10 8 inches long and
it gets us all the way to the end of the
lizard's tail and they say what is the
length of the lizard's body entailed
together well that's going to be the
length of the body plus the length of
the tail
so you have 17 8 plus 10 8 well that's
going to get you to
17 plus 10
plus 10 8 which is equal to
which is equal to 27
27 over eight and so this mark right
over here is 27 over eight and if you
wanted to write this as a mixed number
you could just say well eight goes into
27 three times and you have a remainder
of three so this is equal to three
and three eighths and you see that on
the ruler right over here it's equal to
one
two three and then we have another one
two three eights these two things are
equivalent